it's happened valerant just got what
might be its most controversial update
yet Riot has now made it easier to
identify when smokes are about to fade a
change as simple as this has absolutely
split the community with half embracing
the added accessibility and others
believing that this is just another step
towards making valerent too
[Music]
easy this past Friday we saw some
proposed Chang es to valerant smokes
leaked on Twitter and as of today 7.8
patch Astra brim and Omen smokes now
play a visual and audio Q 1.5 seconds
before they
disappear this seemingly harmless change
thrust the community into a small civil
war with many complaining that this was
oversimplifying a major gameplay
mechanic our very own Nile even made the
joke that Riot is just one step closer
to playing the game for us however with
all the negative feedback I saw there
was also plenty of those defending the
choice arguing that it wouldn't impact
high levels of play and only help newer
players now although I do have my own
opinions on the matter I had no clue
people were this passionate about smokes
in valerant even here at home Liz and
Nile have had their own heated
disagreements so I wanted to hear them
make their cases as an astroman I think
the change is fine Viper wall has a
signal as to when it's running out
Harbor's orb too I don't think that has
catastrophically impacted the game yes
maybe it does make things easier but for
casual low ELO folks this helps them
focus on more macro ideas does this
really dramatically affect how you take
fights your agent comp your positioning
your timing your map awareness your
other ability usage among many other
things I argue that it doesn't all right
I get what Liz is saying but I don't
like the change it's weird for Riot to
suddenly lower the skill floor 3 and 1/2
years after after valerent release when
it first came out I was looking for ways
to improve and although my mechanics may
have lagged behind I could make up for
it with some decent game sense I think
having an internal clock and knowing
things like smoke timings and cooldowns
is important in a lot of games anyone
who wants to improve at a game will put
in time to learn these things smoke
timings are just basic game knowledge
and I agree with booo that knowing them
should just be common practice and
considering most flash durations are
under 2 seconds I think 1 Point 5
Seconds might feel longer than you think
all right so as you can see this was far
from a simple update but I suspect that
all of this uproar has less to do with
the change to smokes themselves and more
to do with the idea of increased
accessibility I do see both sides of the
issue on one hand does valerant really
need more audio and visual clutter I
mean it's not that distracting from what
we've seen But as we know this [__] can
add up but on the other hand even though
Counter-Strike smokes don't have a sound
cue they do Fade and and that fading has
always played a role in how timings work
it's also something I just don't really
think about playing around smoke Fades
is second nature to most Counter-Strike
players and honestly I won't be
surprised if we say the same thing about
valerent new smokes in just a short
while that being said I can't help but
ask myself who wanted this I've never
been playing valerent and thought to
myself damn I wish I knew when this
smoke was going to end so I'm very
curious if Riot has evidence that this
makes valerant a better experience for
newer players now I will say that just a
few days before the league a clip went
viral that perfectly showcased just how
complicated valerant can be at times let
me Al though no no I'm still going to my
God Thanos is
here excuse
me help I haven't been able to hear 55 F
bro what is going
on a War I fought a the battle of
thermop just now I wonder if RI believes
that these changes to the smokes will
help mitigate some of the noise that
people have to deal with in any given
round was adding more Visual and audio
elements to the game the answer
personally I don't think so but only
time will tell what the effect is
regardless I think the bigger question
is if Riot is going to change anything
else is this just the start of a series
of updates aimed at making the game
easier there are already a lot of small
details that make valerant a more
userfriendly experience there are also
details that make it an undoubtedly more
simplified game at least strategically
speaking like the fact that you can see
the enemy team's economy or who has
their alt and when they use them down
could take things a step further by
adding the timers for enemy abilities a
bomb clock who knows what else I mean we
have already seen changes like this in
their other games including the
conversations that followed back when
they added jungle timers to League
people freaked out that they made the
game too easy everyone has pretty much
gotten used to it by now but it still
doesn't change the fact that this aspect
of the game has has been forever altered
now in the case of valerant whether it's
too minuscule to even notice is a
completely other conversation but you
can't deny that these changes to the
smokes will simplify the game even just
a tiny bit Riot is always pushing to
make their games as popular as possible
and sometimes simplifying things is the
most effective way to do that but in the
process of making the game more friendly
to newcomers do you actually sacrifice
the skill cealing part of me is still
split I honestly don't think this is
going to affect the way I play the game
whatsoever but I still find myself
agreeing with Nile and booo maybe
knowing smoke timings is just the bare
minimum at the pro level sure we
probably won't notice a difference just
by watching but behind the scenes do
these added accessibility features
reduce the complexity of the game at
least strategically how much of the game
truly just comes down to gunfights and
abilities let me know if you have any
strong opinions about this change do you
love it do you hate it do you think that
valerant is truly becoming too easy or
do you think that people are just
overexaggerating as per usual
uh I think the audio is silly I think
the audio like I understand because it's
like if you're not looking at the smoke
then you can hear and you're like okay
the Smoke's done but like it just seems
like there's so much going on in the
game audio and visual wise that like
adding more it just seems like uh you're
shooting yourself in the foot a bit